[Musik]
ich bin ja der lösch 29 jahre alt
geboren in wien aufgewachsen im
waldviertel und bin dann 2007 nach der
matura nach innsbruck also nach tirol
übersiedelt wurde jetzt das seit zehn
jahren in tirol
ich sitze dann verkehrsunfall 1994 im
rollstuhl
ich habe mich damals vom rollstuhl dann
einfach nicht bremsen lassen bin genauso
mit mein bruder daneben skater park
herum geschossen und damit die burschen
im dorf den fußball gespielt also ich
war dann halt immer die torfrauen so
also 996 waren die alpinen
weltmeisterschaften für eben parker
sportler in lech am arlberg also in
österreich und damals hat dafür eine
kurze zusammenfassung gezeigt und der
mich im fernsehen gesehen und ich habe
einfach beschlossen dass schott so cool
aus das will ich auch unbedingt machen
[Musik]
ich studiere politikwissenschaften habe
es auch eine weile mit just probiert das
liegt dazu allerdings momentan ein
bisschen ad acta war es einfach von der
zeit her schwer zu machen ist ich bin
jetzt seit anfang november sprich wenn
wir mit ersten elf beim bundesheer im
herz lacht und sportzentrum in innsbruck
stationiert
und das ist für mich natürlich ein
immenser fortschritt gewesen einfach
weil ich jetzt endlich geschafft
versichert bin die finanzielle
unterstützung in sachen wir es auch die
logistische unterstützung ist ziemlich
cool wie zum beispiel eben bei uns wir
müssen uns unsere rennanzüge speziell
anpassen und da habe ich auch dann
gleich für die unterstützung dafür
bekommen und so weiter
also ja es ist für mich wirklich tolle
sache dass ich dabei sein kann
mein persönliches highlight auch von von
der ganzen entwicklungsgeschichte her
sind eigentlich die weltmeisterschaften
im panorama in kanada 2015
weil da bin ich wenige tage vor der
abfahrt im training ziemlich abgeflogen
also so hermann maiers teil in den
zahnreihen über uns drüber und hinterm
zaun noch einmal überschlagen und haben
aber zum glück geben nichts getan und
bin dann drei tage später abfall zu
einer meisterin geworden also es war ist
einfach so für mich der wichtigste
erfolg bisher
ich werde in allen bewerben an den start
gehen sprich eben genauso wie bei denen
ich bin nicht nach mit abfahrt super g
riesentorlauf slalom und eben die kombi
die wahrscheinlich auch bei uns ein
letztes mal stattfinden wird also die
größten chancen habe ich sicher in den
speeddisziplinen und im ries
darauf meine größte konkurrenz kommt
eigentlich aus deutschland also da gibt
es eben zwei mädels stimmen fangen wir
mit allem ziemlich um die ohren fahren
phasenweise und daneben in den schnellen
sachen sind auch noch die mädels aus
japan und aus den usa meine
lieblingsdisziplin ist und bleibt die
abfahrt und da fehlt mir einfach bei den
paralympics die goldene noch deswegen
ist das irgendwie für mich das
wichtigste rennen das es so dass von mir
eben kommen zwei leute mit nämlich mein
onkel und meine tante die werden mehr
vor ort die daumen drücken und die waren
auch die letzten drei mal spreche
integrieren und in sotschi und in
vancouver schon dabei die die wissen wie
der hase läuft und was ich das einfach
fort und zu hause habe ich natürlich
auch eine sehr sehr große fangemeinde
und ja in vorderster front war sicher
mein freund die daumen drücken
er hat auch schon versprochen dass er
hin und wieder mal aufstehen wird in der
fritz im rennen schauen ja und wird dann
hat er mich hoffentlich nicht so sehr
vermissen wie ich ihn
[Musik]